hey everyone
welcome it's been a long time since we
did one of these
sessions thanks for
joining us here you may know this is a
special week
for us at world science festival we're
in the midst of our australian version
of the world science festival world
science festival brisbane
so welcome to
all of you folks from down under
thanks for uh joining us here for this
conversation with brian schmidt
who of course is in australia and we're
going to talk about
his work in understanding the
accelerated nature of the expansion of
space the future of the cosmos i think
it's set on the still image the role of
science and shape in the future yeah
we'll talk a little bit about that but
that makes it sound almost like a
policy talk that's not what we're doing
we're talking about science with perhaps
a little bit of
a policy mixed in
there at the end
you may notice that my background's a
little bit different those of you are
familiar with these conversations from
the past
for the last year we have been in
upstate new york
hiding out if you will
from the scourge that has been ravaging
the world
we are back now in new york city so
actually this is my home in manhattan
not far from the campus of
columbia university so on occasion you
actually may see my kids walk
by behind me maybe they'll even pop in
their head to ask me you know what are
we having for dinner or something like
that but
we will just roll with whatever happens
so before we begin i'll bring brian
schmidt in in just a few minutes
i always like to have a little
discussion
about some news things that have been
happening in physics and it's been kind
of an interesting couple of weeks for
those of you who have been following
these ideas
there is data
tentative data for sure out of cern
regarding
some
decay products of a cork known as the
the b
cork or the beauty cork or the bottom
cork or however you want to call it
where the decay products are not quite
in line with what we would expect from
the standard model of particle physics
standard model particle physics as many
of you know is the fundamental
description of all of the stuff the
particulate ingredients that
make up everything in the world around
us and beyond the things in the world
around us even the more exotic things
that we don't encounter in everyday life
which makes use of some of the heavier
of the cork species you and i we're made
mostly of up quarks down quarks gluons
with electrons and a few other
smattering of particles mixed in but
they're more exotic versions of quarks
that you are familiar with the top quark
and bottom quark being the two heaviest
of those
and the beautiful thing in the standard
model of particle physics is that the
particles can be organized in what we
call families or generations right
you've got the
electron you got the muon you got the
tau these are
three electron like particles that
differ as far as the standard model of
particle physics is concerned they
differ only in their mass
they don't differ in their interactions
they don't differ in their electric
charge how they talk to the
electromagnetic force and they don't
differ
in their weak nuclear charge how they
talk to the weak nuclear interactions
but the data coming out of cern is
suggesting that maybe they do differ
in their interactions in some subtle way
because the decay products that are
being witnessed are not following the
pattern that you would expect if there
is so-called lepton universality that
the
different leptons electron muon tau and
so forth that their interactions may not
be identical
now are we confident of that data no not
at all
it's what's called a three sigma effect
three sigma effect it's not a no it's
not a trivial effect
but there's a chance that it could be a
statistical fluke an anomaly normally
the gold standard for achieving
a discovery is a five sigma level effect
and we're not at that level as yet so
this could certainly go away could
evaporate excitement could dissipate
but it is interesting to see that there
is even today the capacity
of experiments
that are ongoing
to perhaps
give us deep insight into the nature of
the world surprising insight so we'll
see how that one goes
another
big announcement that you may have
followed
perhaps closer to the conversation that
we're going to have with brian schmidt
is to do with
the event horizon telescope
remember the event horizon telescope it
gave us our first
ever
image direct image we often call it a
photograph it's not exactly a photograph
but it's a it's a radio telescope
version of a photograph of a black hole
i think we have that image here if we
can bring that up you yeah there it is
that famous black hole image
that's a black hole in the galaxy m87
giant elliptical galaxy 55 million light
years away
that is a monstrous black hole billions
of times the mass of the sun
and that of course electrified the
physics community the astronomy
community and the world
when this image was released by the
event horizon telescope team shep dolmen
and his colleagues because
it's the most direct
evidence that these
monsters of the cosmos actually exist
einstein's mathematics which einstein
himself resisted long ago
showed the possibility of black holes
being real but how wonderful to actually
see one and you of course know
that the
nobel prize this year was awarded for
indirect data establishing the existence
of black holes roger penrose
mathematical insights of course we had a
nice conversation with him in one of
these
interviews that we've been taking that
we've been having over the last year or
so and roger's work of course was all
mathematical
but
the other work had to do
with the emotion of stars whipping
around the center of the milky way
galaxy giving us strong but indirect
evidence that a black hole resides at
the center of our galaxy
and then the event horizon telescope
subsequently gave the world this very
direct image of a black hole but what
has happened since
is that the event horizon telescope has
done more refined analysis
of the data and the analysis that
they've done is to measure not just the
intensity
of the radio waves but they're
polarization right you may recall that
radio waves it's a form of light and a
particular
wavelength of light and as light
oscillates the electromagnetic fields
oscillate there can be a directionality
to
those
electromagnetic oscillations that
direction is called polarization that's
why you have polarized sunglasses right
as light bounces off a surface it
typically becomes polarized so if you
have these glasses that only allow
light that oscillates in one orientation
through the lenses it will help to block
some light block the glare making it
easier to see
so these folks at the event horizon
telescope have in essence used a
polarized version of the earlier
experiment to have a more refined
measurement of
the plane in which the electromagnetic
fields are oscillating and that data
gives insight into things like the
magnetic field that is swirling around
the black hole itself so i think that
image we probably have that one too
yeah it kind of looks like the other
image but you can see there's kind of
striations
in the data and those striations are
giving information about the
polarization of the light
which ultimately
will be used to give insight into the
nature of the electromagnetic fields the
magnetic field in particular that is
twisted up in the vicinity of
the black hole itself so this is
exciting here's a nice yeah comparison
thank you for whoever brought that up on
the screen so we can see the original
image on well it's on my left as i look
on the screen i don't things may be
reversed as you're looking at it but you
see this dry aided version on my further
to my right
and that is the more refined data so
it's a beautiful experiment
rightly lauded as really the first
direct confirmation of black holes
and now shep has
noted that the
step that he imagines
pursuing is to not just have static
images of black holes but to have
cinematic
radio telescopic images of black holes
have movies
and those movies will allow
the scientists to track
the qualities of the radiation around
the black hole the magnetic fields
around the black hole as they change
over time and that
is an exciting next step i don't know
when that will be achieved but that's
what the astronomers are headed toward
so in a couple minutes i'm going to
bring in
brian schmidt but before i do that i
just want to give a little bit of
introduction to
his work you note that i always try to
frame the conversation a little bit
brian has made profound contributions to
our understanding of the cosmos
and
the perhaps most well-known
and the most
profound insights came from
his work some years ago
studying the rate of expansion of the
cosmos as we've discussed many times in
these conversations the expectation that
went all the way back
to the early years of the 20th century
with albert einstein's general theory of
relativity
in the hands of
the belgian priest george lemaitre in
the hands
of the russian
physicist alexander friedman and others
as well who were applying einstein's
ideas to the entire cosmos
the expectation was that sure the
universe is expanding but it should be
slowing down in its expansion the reason
for that is completely intuitive we have
like a little
video if you if you were to toss an
apple up into the air right we all know
what happens the apple goes up
but it goes up slower and slower over
time because the earth pulls on it
similarly the pull
of each galaxy on every other the
expectation was it would slow down
the cosmic
exodus that was what was supposed to
happen right so brian schmidt
others as well that we have spoken to
spread out on a couple of teams adam
marie saul perlmutter others as well
instrumental in
the work that we're gonna talk about
but their motivation
initially and maybe i'm wrong maybe
brian will correct me i'm guessing i
think that their motivation was to
measure the rate of cosmic slowdown that
was what the project was about to put
some quantitative might behind this
expectation that the expansion should
slow over time
but the remarkable thing as we will
discuss
is that when the data finally came in
and was carefully analyzed
they got kind of the shock of a lifetime
that
the rate of expansion was not slowing
down the rate of expansion was speeding
up so i think we have a little
little visual on that
they found that the rate at which
galaxies were moving apart was going
faster and faster and faster over time
you see a little smoky white stuff there
that's our
schematic poetic metaphorical image of
what is known as dark energy as we will
see
the belief is that there is this dark
energy in space it doesn't look so dark
it was dark you couldn't see it so we
made it smoky white but this dark energy
can give rise to a kind of repulsive
gravitational push
that drives everything apart
not the attractive version of gravity
that the expectation was would pull
everything back together
so that discovery
has kind of revolution revolutionized
our thinking
about how the universe is changing over
time and it certainly revolutionizes our
understanding of what the universe will
be like in the in the far future i think
with one final
animation before we turn to bring brian
into the conversation directly
if
this accelerated expansion continues
unabated
the amazing thing is in roughly 100
billion trillion years whatever
the distant galaxies will be driven away
so fast faster than the speed of light
that an astronomer in the far future
looking into the night sky
they won't be able to see those distant
galaxies
if they're moving away faster than the
speed of light the light they emit will
not be able to reach us and so the dark
night sky will truly look dark
as we see here don't don't take this
image away this isn't
a filler image this isn't a transition
image this blackness
represents what the cosmos
may in fact look like in a trillion
years from now that's kind of
an amazing thing because
our understanding that the universe is
expanding has come to us by the study of
the motion of distant galaxies if you
can't see distant galaxies in the future
how will you even know that the universe
is expanding
right i mean sometimes people say well
you'll know it because earlier
generations will have passed on that
knowledge that understanding
but i'm fond of asking
the question which i'll ask you all
right now which is
you know
if you have a powerful telescope 100
you know a trillion years from now right
100 billion trillion years whatever and
you use that powerful telescope to look
in the night sky and you only see
darkness
and you think that we're just an island
oasis floating in a sea of blackness and
then someone comes to you with this
textbook
from like a trillion years earlier
right
and they hand you this dusty textbook
and you open it up you know careful not
to have the pages crumble
and this textbook talks about a universe
chock full of galaxies all moving apart
from each other
and if they try to convince you that the
universe was like that in the past
and that all those galaxies have
disappeared over kind of cliff at the
edge of space
are you going to believe them are you
going to believe this ancient knowledge
you're going to believe your own
state-of-the-art observations which
suggest that there's nothing else out
there but blackness you know i don't
know
you can answer for yourself but i think
most of us would be inclined
to not trust
trillion-year-old mythology about how
the universe was
and rather believe what we actually see
anyway we'll ask brian schmidt that
question in due course but
with that let me
let me bring
brian into the conversation i believe
that he is with us
and as he's brought in hey brian how are
you
good morning slash evening yeah exactly
let me just remind everybody who is with
us here that brian schmidt is a
distinguished professor of astronomy and
the 12th vice chancellor and president
of the australian
national university he completed his
astronomy master's degree in 92 and phd
from harvard in 93
and for his work as i mentioned on the
accelerating universe he was awarded the
2011 nobel prize in physics jointly with
adam reese and
saul pearl mudder so thank you for
taking time out to
join us it's good to see you i think the
last time i saw you was
when i was in australia for
a world science festival event some
years ago i don't remember which one
that was you
i think it was i think it was two or
three years ago uh seems like a lifetime
ago now i'm afraid yeah right exactly
how have you got well you guys are doing
much better than we are right well yeah
so we've been covered free here in
canberra since uh june so life in
canberra is very normal as in pretty
much since june so
we're you know our classes and
everything are normal but
the covet 19 is now out in brisbane uh
and
you know it's quite interesting because
we dna trace every single covet case now
so they can tell exactly where it came
from and they know there's an
intermediary which is unknown and so
we'll see i have a feeling brisbane's
gonna have to shut down because
as you know exponentials which we use in
cosmology there's one stable number
which is zero
otherwise we're growing or decaying
yeah it's an amazing thing how people's
intuition about exponentials is so
modest compared to the intuition that we
need i mean by the time you realize that
something's exponentially growing it's
too late
yeah you know you have to be
thinking you know many e-folds ahead of
where you currently are if there's any
chance of stemming the tide but i was
told that at world science festival
brisbane
people were packed into the the concert
hall without masks is that
i mean is that craziness or i mean
it was absolutely fine until
yesterday and as soon as you have it so
when you have nothing you have nothing
to fear and so
uh the problem is now we know there's a
case out and that means there's probably
10 cases out and so i'm i fear that
brisbane is going to have to shut down
hard
because
i i think we've decided after getting
all this way without killing
uh millions of people it's probably good
to stay that way and what about the rest
of australia
similar situation or
yeah so uh it's been you know there's
been these little flash lockdowns where
we are shut down to get it back down to
zero again
but uh most of australia right now uh
melbourne had a big breakout and was
shut down for 112 days
but uh most of australia is like
canberra canberra's just been the
longest period of time
so we've been very lucky and can i say
canberra's been quite interesting it's
been very open and we've just had very
good contact tracing and very sensible
public health policy here
yeah that's what leadership does
right compared to evidence informed
leadership and in our case our
our government is not any particularly
different than yours but it uh it
panicked and it panicked and actually
decided to better listen to the
scientists which was quite refreshing
wait are you trying to say that that's a
that's a modest difference from the
administration that we had here that
feels pretty significant
it doesn't normally panic and ask
scientists for help but it did in this
case and we're all very grateful yeah
absolutely so are you now
planning
um remote classes or
are you not at that stage yet
no well we are our classes on campus are
happening right now uh we are open in
in class classes as per normal
we do have
a large number of students who are
stranded overseas because our borders
are closed and so we are sort of having
to run two streams so we have the online
stream and we have the on-campus stream
but the on-campus stream right now is
no mask there are restrictions of
numbers of people per square meter but
that's really the only difference yeah
you know it's interesting i got an email
from our colleague paul davies just uh
like a week or two ago and i had no idea
that he went to brisbane for
the world science festival last year i
guess he went a little bit early because
it was shut down before we took our
flight so we never came to australia
but he flew to australia and then
got kind of trapped there he said for
364 days he only recently uh
left
so that could have been our situation
just by a couple not that it would have
been
bad to be i promise you australia is
very good at having people leave the
country not so good at letting them yeah
right right exactly um but look we're
looking forward to coming back uh next
year assuming the world will be at that
place
but i was thought that we'd do here if
it's okay with you i obviously would
like to talk about
some of the
vital work that you and your colleagues
have achieved
but we often spend a little time on the
journey that got you to the place
that allowed you to do that work
and you know i you know i know that you
you grew up in america obviously even
though you're in australia it was
montana is that montana in alaska so i
lived until i was uh 13 in montana and
then moved up to alaska
and was that your parents work or what
drew you to alaska
uh yeah so
uh my
dad grew up in my mom grew up in eastern
montana they met
i was what they call a sophomore
surprise uh at the university of montana
in 1967.
uh and then my father was a biologist my
mother uh did a number of things you
know had a master's degree
and so
we lived with my father doing various
biology work
uh until we moved up to alaska and my
father ended up working first on a big
project up there with respect to a dam
that never happened but then he went on
to become effectively the uh state
fisheries biologist for the state of
alaska
ended up leaving the state when he uh
upset the governor by shutting down the
salmon fisheries which is you know that
is
i don't know there's nothing worse you
can do it's like
you know trying to have an uh in indiana
to shut down the basketball team
why did you do that what was the
motivation
well the motivation is is that uh you
know salmon come in and have variations
each year
and they have returns it was very clear
it was a very poor return
and so that if you don't let the salmon
through
then
uh you end up killing the run later on
and so there's you're trying to his his
job is to optimize
uh
for the number of salmon in in the
rivers and so not interestingly enough
his problem was not the commercial
fisheries who get it but it was the
the fishermen on the shore you know the
the the non-commercial yeah
did they try to run you out of town or
anything i mean was it uncomfortable
well i mean this was after i was already
uh in you know actually finished my phd
so well they just you know they they do
what as politicians do they shut down
his lab and
all the other things
yeah well he decided my dad is not a
politician he's just you know straight
down the line uh
uh fisheries biologist and
anyway so he he immigrated to canada
after that
probably a wise move
so um did you have any
interest in going into biology was that
ever
in the cards or it was always more in
yeah well i always knew i was going to
do science uh and you know i grew up
with my dad because i was born when my
parents were 19 and 20. so i you know my
dad had child care duties and i used to
go into the lab with him
an awful lot when he was doing his phd
so i was i was around the science i
always gravitated to physical science
though uh even from a young person i was
pretty sure i was going to do
meteorology i just love the weather i
still love the weather i'm just
fascinated by it
and i'm a weather freak
but
i always wanted to do that and then when
i was 16 i volunteered to work a summer
at the anchorage forecast center which
was sort of my dream job
but it was all the information and
science came down from oklahoma and you
just kind of went and read forecasts and
stuff and i didn't find it what i was
expecting and so i was suddenly like my
god what am i going to do that's not
what i was thinking i was going to do
now
in retrospect
all of the stuff i wanted to do which is
to actually build the models and stuff
that came out of oklahoma that would
have been exactly the type of thing i
wanted to do but rather i went and did
astronomy and physics instead but it's
interesting because
you know when i think about the weather
and meteorology
it feels like such an incredibly complex
problem that applying fundamental
physics to it
we've we've made headway on it but
compared to the fundamental physics
that's so clean and relatively simple of
of cosmology and astrophysics simple
astrophysical systems it seems like
they're almost a universe apart from
each other no
well i think they're equivalent to
people who work on doing giant star
formation simulations where you've got
the hydrodynamics mixed in
with the simpler bits and you know it's
essentially the same physical equations
between the two and and i don't mind a
little bit and and you know with respect
to
you know i i
some people will know that i have a
vineyard and a winery here
i use now 14 day forecasts for looking
at rain and precipitation which are
85 90 accurate now ten years ago they
were they were useless they didn't even
give them to you they were useless so
they've made a lot and it's it's
computational grunt in the same way you
know my guys up at stromlo who are doing
star formation stuff i mean honest to
god when they put together a galaxy now
it looks like a galaxy as opposed to
some little toy model it's pretty
frightening what
that physics and lots of computational
corrupt gives you yeah yeah and so
what did you do your your phd on what
was the uh focus there
so i did my phd at harvard on measuring
distances to type two supernovae these
are the massive stars that live for
let's say 10 million years they're often
10 to 20 times the mass of our sun
and at the end of their lives
uh they form a neutron star or possibly
a black hole probably both
and as they collapse you get a an
essentially
a
shock wave it's it's it's a little bit
of bounce but it's probably a lot of
neutrinos which normally of course go
right through the earth
things are so dense at that neutron star
that they actually the neutrinos end up
blowing the the object apart quite
remarkable
and uh you know these are the things
that make uh
most of the interesting elements oxygen
carbon iron those things are all
dispersed and created in these
explosions and i was able to use them to
measure distances
in an absolute
manner where you actually modeled the
exploding star using those weather-like
equations pretty messy actually relative
to cosmology equations uh and we could
essentially figure out how many watts
they were how big the light bulb was
and of course if you know how many watts
light bulb is and you know how bright it
appears here it gets fainter the further
away it is then i can read off the
wattage measure how bright it appears
here and measure the distance
yeah
and so i'm trying to measure the hubble
constant uh which i did and i got an
interesting number which was 73
kilometers per second per megaparsec
which i'm proud to say is exactly what
adam reese is still getting all these
years later that's pretty good
absolutely and so was
your work then was a blending of of
observation and and simulation and
calculation or did it skew one way or
the other among those elements
well uh you know a lot of good things in
life you do as a team so ron eastman and
bob kirsten being my phd superman uh
supervisor ron eastman
uh
who uh is silicon valley area now
uh he did uh most of the really detailed
calculations you know ten years worth of
work to build
uh a model
uh which had all of the
the the right um ingredients to
essentially calculate and so i was
involved in the periphery of certain
aspects of that but i
uh i used that
with ron to to do all the calculations
we needed to measure the distance so i
actually ended up wanting more models
than ron ever did because i was so
enthusiastic about using them where ron
was always trying to get the little bits
and pieces right i was like okay let's
just go forth and see what's going on so
we actually made a pretty good team
and and so did you actually
go to telescopes to do these
observations or were you using data that
others were acquiring how did that how
did that work out yeah a little bit of
both um so in
1991 so my second year my phd i went and
spent uh about two and a half months
down in chile
with the guys at sarah tololo so um we
had
mark phillips is who i uh was invited
down by but with nick
uh and mario hawi was there and so they
had gathered a bunch of data for the
column tololo
supernova search which was really
targeting the other type of supernovae
type 1a supernovae which are the
explosions of white dwarfs and so they
had these little other things type 2
supernovae they didn't want to use so
i observed down there i reduced a lot of
data i observed a lot of supernovae up
at in arizona using the telescopes that
harvard had so it was a bit of new data
a bit old data
and when did you start then to
move more toward a cosmological focus i
mean obviously it seems like a natural
progression because you're studying the
same kinds of stellar systems you know
from 30 000 feet they're roughly the
same but was there a moment when
cosmology became
your
passion or was it just the sort of
natural progression of the uh the
projects
i always wanted to do cosmology so i was
measuring the hubble constant and you
know i remember
when i started my phd at harvard bob was
wanting me to do an ultraviolet bob
kirschner wanted wanting me to do an
ultraviolet violet study of supernova
1987a and i was like that's fine but
what i really want to do is this project
and they said oh that's a great project
if you want to do it it's what i did my
thesis on is what bob kirschner said so
i wanted to measure the hubble constant
uh and of course the reason i wanted to
measure the hubble constant is it was
easier with the technology of the time
than trying to measure uh q naught as we
called it which is the deceleration
parameter
uh and but i always had an eye to
wanting to measure
q naught uh as you know my ultimate goal
and so when i finished my phd
having worked with the team down in
chile
i realized there was an opportunity
uh saul pearl mudder at berkeley had
demonstrated you could find supernovae
type 1a very large distances and my
colleagues in chile had demonstrated you
could measure distances with them very
accurately
and
i thought
the
supernova community should come together
because we you know saul and his team
were deeply physics culture
and uh there was a huge divide in 1993
94 between the physics culture and the
astronomy culture
uh we both kind of pointed at each other
and made fun of each other would be i
think a good way to describe it
and it was clear we weren't going to be
able to easily work together so you know
i when i finished my phd
talked to nick sunset when i was down in
chile and said
let's measure qnap with this we can do
it uh i will go through and write the
software we need to do all this stuff
because we didn't have any software and
so that's what i did is my first
beginning of my postdoc i went focused
everything into this this project
related to my phd but quite different
and
was i correct in my little introductory
remark that you
thought
that you were going to nail down this
deceleration parameter give a
quantitative value for it
did you think that you could be on the
cusp of
a radically different conclusion from
that work or was that just never part of
the thinking
well
so
uh
the idea of a cosmological constant goes
back to 1917
and it's sort of been a cosmologist
graveyard
so we made fun of the cosmological
constant sean carroll who was my office
mate
wrote a review
um in 1992 for the big uh astronomy
reviews program and i remember
him going through and alan sandage had
done the review with little yellow
post-its and there were like thousands
of post-its in this little review i'm
watching him struggle and go through
this and i'm like sean
why are you wasting your time on the
cosmological constant when we all know
it's a joke so
we knew about it but it was it was a
joke it was it was the thing that people
refer to
when they got the wrong answer that that
is its history and so when you suddenly
get the wrong answer as we'll describe
later on
you feel like you're part of a bad joke
but it is a bad joke that has
an illustrious history right i mean the
first person to tell this bad joke
was albert einstein right i mean so i
guess that's an example of what you're
saying you know he is looking at the
equations of general relativity can't
get a static solution out of the math as
this philosophical prejudice shared by
most everybody in the world who was
thinking about these things that there
should be a static solution and as you
say he forces one into the math by
introducing
this cosmological constant
um
but uh he then smacks himself in the
head when the observations show that the
universe is not static and i guess
that's the first example of where this
becomes perhaps a joke or the the bad
punch line to a joke and he's stuck with
it though for a while interestingly
enough if you look at his visit in
caltech
in 1930 31 he still has landom up on the
board and in that very famous interview
that was done um
by
gamov
done in german often saying it was my
greatest mistake he didn't say it was my
greatest mistake bruno livengood in our
team who actually reads german said he
said
i was acting like a donkey with the
cosmological constant
very stubborn
huh
you know it's interesting because in the
1931 32 period there's another
quote of his that i read i i don't know
if it's in a paper or if it's in some
media account but einstein actually says
i can't get it exactly but it says
something like only future observations
of the expansion of space will determine
whether or not there's a cosmological
constant he actually says that back in
the 1930s so you're absolutely right the
uh the lore
that he just immediately discarded it
and and and you know ruled the day when
he introduced it
that's a little overblown
you know and we also remember in um
belgium in 1927
georges lamotte who you talked about
earlier
and you pronounce his name with such
more finesse than i do so
the french the french have just cringed
at both of us but
the uh
but george lamont showed him his phd
thesis which he was working on at mit
remotely
and my guess is georges le mans was one
of those people who was really annoying
but
uh he basically showed here look at the
data of hubble and slifer the universe
is expanding here's the equations that i
have derived and
and einstein reportedly said
well your equations have already been um
derived by friedman
and you're
uh
you
he said something you are a much better
mathematician than a physicist or
something like that yeah i think
your math is correct but your physics is
abominable yeah that's that's right and
pretty much just missed him out of hand
so porch george lamont who did
everything
gets pipped at the post by hubble two
years later who
um did did a lot of the hard
observational work but uh yeah oh well
it's life well you know it's an amazing
example of inner fortitude i mean i
think if i went to einstein with an idea
and einstein told me that my physics was
abominable i probably would have changed
careers or
hidden under a rock or something but you
know you know
that isn't the case with you know george
and he actually
stays with it and pushes this idea
forward
yeah uh and yeah he was he was uh
i said must have been an interesting
character
yeah yeah yeah absolutely i mean you
know it's unusual to have uh
you know
training in physics and to be ordained
um you know the pope at the time i
forget which pope it was
got wind of his work in cosmology
and described it as
giving a confirmation of the story of
genesis
and this to lemaitre was
absolutely mortifying because he had
diligently and carefully drawn a line
between
his theological his religious side of
his being and this sort of scientific
side now if you're gonna do work in
science that has to do with the origin
of the universe you shouldn't be too
surprised that it's going to be you know
crossing over but it was something that
he found very difficult
when the
the religious community kind of glommed
on to his work as some kind of
confirmation of the
the ideas in the bible um so yeah i
imagine you know i don't know a lot
about his personal story but i can't
imagine this must have been a difficult
difficult period for him but
nevertheless so
this is the sort of first introduction
of the cosmological constant then
ultimately it does go away
from mainstream thinking in the
cosmological scenario
really it pops up i guess now and then
in the 70s and earlier
60s alan sandedge first uh measurement
of it cosmological constant beatrice
tinsley
the guys uh looking at no i'm sorry i
don't know that name who who is that
uh great yale astronomer she died young
but she was one of the the great uh
re-emergence of women in astronomy uh so
new zealander but uh at yale did a lot
of stuff in uh stellar astronomy but
went through and basically said the k
corrections
uh the the growth what happened is she
was looking at the work of sandage and
colleagues
and the big galaxies have evolving
stellar populations and when she
corrected for those because they had
been so assumed to be static
uh she found evidence for a cosmological
constant now
like
what sort of value
oh
you know
close to close to right what we're at
today
but the uncertainties in the evolution
even today are too much but uh it was
interesting that they weren't even
worrying about the evolving stellar
populations back then so yeah big change
and then the i think really the really
interesting one just to show you where
people go askew on this in the late 60s
we saw all of these quasars which are
these bright black holes it turns out
um peaking at a red shift of two so
about eight billion years in the past
and it turns out that you can create
what's called a loitering model where
you have just enough cosmological
constant that the universe is slowing
down due to gravity and the cosmological
constant
which has that repulsive gravity
kicks in at exactly the right time and
the universe kind of stalls and so the
idea was maybe the universe stalled back
to uh eight billion years ago
and that's what we were seeing that
became quite hot for a couple years
again absolutely not correct it just
turns out there were a lot of black
holes eight billion years ago that were
really bright yeah right right
and so then this gradually leads us to
the work of you and your colleagues
trying to measure the
rate of cosmological slowdown in the
outward expansion
and so
when did you when did when did that work
begin proper was that early 90s was that
sort of the beginning of yeah so uh saul
perlmutter i know you've had a chance to
talk to but he and the group at berkeley
started in
1990 give or take a year or two
uh but they didn't discover their first
object until 1990
i think
uh the technology just wasn't there
uh
so i
started the high z team with nick
sunseft in 1994. i just finished my phd
and so we really started in 1994 but uh
saul and the and co had been working you
know almost four years on it so we had a
lot to catch up and where were you at
that time when you started reminding me
again you were oh i was a uh a cfa a
center for astrophysics fellow where i
spent 18 months before moving to
australia so when i started the work i
was already transitioning to move to
australia jeremy muld one of the leaders
of the hubble key project to measure the
hubble constant had become moved from
caltech to anu where i'm at now still uh
and uh eventually after several attempts
managed to get a job here
so so i moved here at the very end of
94. got it and when when did the data
really start to
have
you know sufficient accuracy that you
could begin to calculate the
deceleration parameter was that
yeah so we took our first data in 95 uh
and almost didn't discover anything it
was a disaster i was trying to run a
telescope with a young baby from
australia when the internet was one
character per second
uh oh god but we did manage to find one
which is what saved our bacon but over
95 96 97
we uh then brought together roughly 20
objects 15 of which were useful
and
so at the very end of 97
and from memory uh talking to adam it
was in november 97
adam
sent me
uh the the the final
uh
data of the distances and the redshift
and said
tell me what you think
and so you know we had independent codes
and i ran it and i'm like uh
something like houston we have a problem
because very clear it indicated that the
universe was
speeding up over time
uh and so from that time in november
adam and i worked very closely together
just to go through literally everything
independently together
in our own way and you know we found
some little mistakes but in the end
uh
by it was the 8th of january 1998
we had gone through every single thing
we agreed we would go through
uh and we were uh at that point having
to tell our team
uh guys this is what the analysis looks
like um
because every person in the team had had
little bits and pieces of it but we had
been doing the final synthesis together
with the resistance in other words
you can well imagine that you don't want
to be the but of another cosmological
constant joke right you know 80 years
later or something so was the resistance
in the team to this conclusion or was it
hey that's what the date is that's what
the data is well it was complete
smattering across the things alex
filippinko
this is right we got to go out nature
paper tomorrow um
bob kirschner
saying
uh yes it's the day to date but our
heart of hearts we know this cannot
possibly be right
uh
you know the very careful
uh nick sunset at bruno livengood
uh
and um mark uh
phillips going through and saying hey
hey we need to go through all of this
bit by bit there's you know this
requires extreme proof now
adam and i had done pretty much all of
that ourselves but the whole team
and you know the basic thing i said is
yes we are scientists we don't like this
answer it is crazy
but we are gonna have to publish it even
if we don't like it if we are convinced
it's correct and we will do every
reasonable test that this team can come
up with adam and i have already done a
lot of them
uh and the reality is i think we had
more or less done every test that people
had asked for but people wanted to do it
their own way in new ways and and we did
that in the end everyone was like
all right we cannot make it go away it
was quite a robust result in the end you
know it was a 15 or 20 effect which you
know uh
for astronomy at the time was pretty
precise but we knew we were we had
things controlled to two or three
percent and i should know the answer to
this i i don't i apologize but you can
tell me immediately so in your paper
did you commit to the cosmological
constant as an explanation or did you
focus for the most part on just here's
the data we have some kind of
accelerated expansion effect but we're
not going to commit to an explanation
for how that could be
no no we we did the full uh analysis and
we said the simplest is a cosmological
constant we then ran
a paper directly after that where we use
we actually did a full marginalization
over the equation of state priors
uh
uh we had the earliest uh cosmic
microwave background flatness priors you
could only do it with uh the fact the
idea that the universe was flat uh and
it's quite interesting things that
people maybe don't realize is that that
1998 paper
was a full bayesian analysis which is a
way of doing statistical treatments that
it's the only way you do them now but
that is literally one of the first
bayesian treatments of cosmological data
ever
is that you're like i did not realize it
okay yeah well the problem is is i
didn't learn any of this in graduate
school
well adam uh being helped by bill press
who was at harvard and taught both of us
uh
my undergraduate advisor actually so uh
all right okay well there you go and or
can in some way
so we were learning bayesian statistics
as part of this because it was almost
impossible to analyze it using the
normal methods of the day because
there's parts of the diagram you're not
allowed to go and with frequent
statistics you just there's just no way
to analyze like that so uh it was quite
an interesting journey uh learning uh
all sorts of new things as we were doing
it
right and and so
uh by january february-ish of 98
the team is convinced
that you've got a shocker of a result
that the universe is speeding up in its
expansion
did you did you coordinate at all with
the other team this all promo or did you
guys just you know let's just all go out
and and make our announcement and just
see what happens
yeah so it was it was hey it was very
competitive at the time you have to
remind our the the two teams
uh
i got along quite well with saul but i
would say there was a lot of hot
competition alex villapinko had switched
teams
uh saul and
bob kirschner were having spats with
gears and goldhaber and people in
between
richard ellis on their side uh throwing
spears as well
uh and we're all pretty good friends now
but i was pretty pretty hot competition
so no we uh
we did not uh
share what each other p each people were
doing one of the interesting things that
had happened
is
on you know the 8th of january we
told our team
my god the universe appears to be
accelerating on the 9th of january uh at
least my time this is australian time
seoul perlmutter showed preliminary
results at the
american astronomical conference
which uh basically
showed an accelerating universe uh but
they hadn't you know there was only in
one color they hadn't corrected for dust
and all these things that we had already
done
and so
that was a big shock to us because three
months earlier
they had essentially
published a result that said the
universe was slowing down quite quickly
so we thought we were getting this
answer that was completely different to
them which was when i say worrying me so
how did that which happened on saul's
team was there re-analysis of the data
or
i
i
they had a lot more data
uh
i will just note i i i don't know it
i'll be honest it still doesn't make
sense to me
the uh the consistency of those first
seven objects that they published
they're just not consistent with the
rest of the data man i can't put it any
other way and they're not they were not
um
easily figured out in in their paper um
i'm afraid
and so in the end of the day would you
say the competition
was good for science or
irrelevant you were going to get there
anyway
what role did it play
uh
it was it was good for science and bad
for science so how was it good for
science um
we worked hard we were careful we knew
we had another team that was going to
spring us
if we did any mistakes
we knew that
we had to use the telescope taunt
absolutely
to highest advantage because if we
didn't they were going to get it so it
really made us sharp on our game that
was good
but i would say the rather toxic
atmosphere between the the two teams
um would have been would have put young
people off um it
it's not anything that i'm i'm proud of
quite the opposite um and i will say
here in australia i kind of kept my head
down
avoided a lot of it but no i i'm not um
i don't i don't think that's the way it
i think it's good to have competition
but it should be done in a collegial
uh
the best for science matter and so i i
think we were just a little too hot to
be honest at the time
but you know when you're competing for
finite resources and you feel like at
any given time the rug is going to be
pulled out from underneath you uh you
act uh in ways that is highly
competitive so it can help us and what
it did help us
really importantly is in 1998 when both
teams basically came out with the answer
at the same time and we were known for
not getting along with each other
uh people like yourself or mike turner
got the megaphone out and said this is
real folks and so rather than being
laughed out of the stadium
sort of like i thought we might be
uh people took it very very seriously
very quickly so i think having we would
only had one team i think it would have
taken until the kazakh microwave
background results got quite good to
resolve right right no i i remember
being i happened to be at a talk that
saul gave
around that time some it was on the west
coast of the united states i can't
remember where it was
and i remember
the electric response in the audience
made it very clear that people were
taking this serious seriously from the
get-go and it could well be because as
you're saying there was knowledge that
two independent teams
that were not chummy were were coming
you know to the same same result
um how long did it take
for the the heat to cool
and turn into
you know the camaraderie of discovery as
opposed to the competition
of trying to get there first
i think it took to the nobel prize
i mean
yeah uh
i think uh
again i had a pretty good
um
you know pretty good relationship um
[Music]
with saul again because i've been
isolated i'm not fighting over the same
u.s resources as everyone else so it it
made it a little easier for me but i i
things
things remained pretty hot until 2011
and then when when that happened i think
people
um made a decision that there was
nothing to fight over anymore so i think
that's how
so the the the the jocular photograph of
you and saul kind of
duking it out
that was around the nobel prize time i
guess well no that was much earlier that
wasn't an aspen meeting oh
and again
again i had quite a good relationship
with saul
uh so that that would have been like a
2004 aspen meeting maybe around that
time
uh but there still was a lot of
animosity between the different
uh power brokers largely in the united
states uh
because we're still doing competing
projects for time and yeah it was pretty
competitive
so so the nobel prize is announced 2011.
um you know that
in many ways is the pinnacle achievement
at least that's how the public sort of
use it in terms of achievement say in
the sciences physics in particular
was that a a radical life-changing
moment or was it just hey this is cool
and you just kind of went on with what
you would have been doing anyway
no it's life-changing um and you know
feynman described it as the worst thing
that ever happened to him in his life
uh for me
you go with the flow and you're right it
is an absolute um especially in a
country like australia where there's a
very small number of them
it it changes
uh your opportunities but it also
changes the demands on your time and you
can
you can just put your head down and say
i'm going to ignore
all of the requests from my time and
keep doing things and that is a
perfectly reasonable way for people to
do things but it makes you
very unpopular
if i can be honest amongst
groups
uh in my case i made the decision to go
with the flow and you know use it as a
way of
promoting science but it does kind of
eat you alive it you become a show pony
uh and it is very difficult to
um
to
to maintain that focus that you need
uh to really do your science you know
you don't do science
uh
10 hours a week between meetings you do
it by focusing your efforts to answer
things so
it was challenging and ultimately the
reason i am running a university right
now
is for me to grab my life back and to
focus on something now running a
university is not anything i ever
thought i would do
uh completely antithetical to my
interest 10 years ago but it's been it's
been a place to
to recapture my my focus uh it's
yeah it's uh i wouldn't recommend it for
most people to be honest it's uh it's an
incredibly challenging job but it does
allow you to do things with the i guess
that the nobel prize opens doors and it
gives you
uh the opportunity to do good uh that
you just didn't have before have you
been able
to mold
the physics astronomy programs in a way
that you feel has had impact is that is
that a part of the focus
certainly uh in before becoming vice
chancellor astronomy in australia is
very much a whole of country
activity we you know we hang together uh
because if we don't we won't survive
so we were able and i was able to help a
fair bit um ensure that we had a vibrant
astronomy program and so that means that
australia
uh you know was part of the giant
magellan telescope we're part of eso
part of ska
so we have a very vibrant strong
astronomy program that i was you know
not alone but helped to to grow now as
vice chancellor of of anu it's not just
physics of course it's uh it's
everything including
questions around our democracy how is
science done how do we
translate science into things and stay
connected to the community how do we
ensure that right now you know 75
percent of australians still see
universities as
uh a highly trusted institution the
highest most trusted institution in
australia where you will see of course
in the united states university's trust
has plummeted so you're really playing
at the very highest level of the
democracy when you run the national
university and that's uh you know i
would have never thought that would be
something i would do but it's something
i'm passionate about and it is something
where i want to ensure that australia
doesn't go down certain paths that i've
seen the us go down uh because it's been
tough to watch so based on on that
experience especially as you've lived in
both countries and
i assume still have a certain affection
for
your country of origin
what advice do you give us over here
because look obviously the transition
from the previous administration to the
current one as a step in in the right
direction but there is a significant
fraction of the general population here
as you're saying who distrust expertise
who distrust anybody that has anything
to do with a university and i'm asked
this question all the time what do we do
thankfully i can now ask you that
question
well
the dutch have an expression that i
think is uh i think very telling which
says
that trust comes in by foot and leaves
on horseback
uh so
the reality is a lot of that trust has
gone and it is going to take a long time
to build back you would think covet 19
which has done a lot to rebuild trust in
australia among some skeptical because
it has literally been life or death
and that clearly has had some effect in
the united states but i think
it is
a little less preaching
it is noticing and understanding
polarization and you know we have to be
cognizant that polarization
has been used as a weapon by
the extremes of u.s society and
the us enemies
people need to understand that u.s
enemies have used polarization
to break the us apart and i think
universities need to
uh step back and rather than saying but
we are right you are wrong
even when that is true to say
how are we going to bring social
cohesion
and that is reaching out
listening and bringing in the people
slowly bit by bit person by person
into
our fold of prosperity i mean the
reality is
in the years to come
if you want to be prosperous you want to
be connected to that university scene
and we need to go into the little towns
of you know
uh of the south of the midwest where i
grew up my family are from those places
and we need to reach back in there make
sure our alumni
and people who have gone out go back
there tell the stories make sure the
sons and daughters of those parts of the
of of the country are welcomed and have
a place
and listen to even if you don't like
what you hear so i think it has to be a
big project but just getting up and
telling people they're idiots turns out
not a very good way no it's it's hugely
refreshing for me to hear you say that
because often times the conversation
over here assumes that people come to
their beliefs about the world through
some kind of
very systematic sequence of rational
judgments you look out at the world you
judge the data you come to a conclusion
and nothing could be further from the
truth the vast majority of people come
to their beliefs by virtue of the group
that they belong to and their identity
is so bound up with that group that if
the group leaves x you believe x because
that is
the group through which your place in
the world is assured and so you're
absolutely right we have to reach out to
those groups listen to the grievances
listen to the perspectives and not slam
it with a hammer of rational discourse
but rather reach out with a with a
warmth and an empathetic perspective in
order to bring everybody ultimately to a
place that i think will be better for
us all and look i mean the world science
festival with one of the wonderful
things in world science festival
brisbane
just to
bring it home to i mean this event is
part of of that celebration of science
world science festival prism goes out
to communities that are not directly in
the heart of major cities
and so we view that as a wonderful model
and our intention in the united states
is to do the same thing to begin to seed
these world science festival events in a
variety of cities and
extra city environments where you don't
necessarily have great population
centers but that is where you're going
to reach people where they're at
and so i think you're absolutely right
that kind of reaching out is the vital
thing that needs to be done um
astronomy and physics is great because
it's not it's not political it's there's
no
it is it is just the wonder that the
world shares and you know when i go to
namibia and i talk to kids there and
look at the sky and tell the story it's
just like going to kuna bara brand where
the observatory is here in history
it is a real universal language yeah no
absolutely and so looking to the future
both from the political standpoint and
from the scientific standpoint
where do you think the great excitement
what are we going to be talking about in
this kind of event 50 years from now
boy it's so hard to know you know
because
the way i think people
think of science being quite linear and
it often is but when it's linear it's
not very interesting uh it's when you
get the big
sudden revolution so you were talking
earlier about this uh
little crack in the door that is
emerging potentially at cern around the
standard model because as you're aware
right now the standard model
is
uh it's in trouble because it's just
been so good at predicting things and
there's just nothing
else to do
although it'd be nice to understand the
mass of the neutrino and what dark
matter is
among other things but um
the
the reality is uh
you know that might be a little crack in
the door that suddenly opens up a new
world in particle physics and how can i
know that but if that door turns out to
be a dead end
and we can't figure out you know why
neutrinos have mass what dark matter is
so let's just say dark matter
only interacts via gravity it is it's a
new type of particle that does not
interact by the other three forces
what kind of screw i just don't know how
we're going to make progress on that
uh
and unless someone like you can come up
with well actually it naturally emerges
from this flavor of string theory and
etc
um
but
what i do know so the things that i feel
confident that we're gonna have linear
progression on
uh
planets
it is there's just a clear path for the
next 50 years to go through and start
finding habitable planets looking at
their atmospheres and potentially even
as we get bigger and bigger telescopes
looking at you know the rotation
revealing continents oceans things like
that that that is
almost guaranteed to happen and that is
going to be exciting
uh we have the ability you know right
now if you look at our
our our map of the universe we've got
the ultrasound photos the cosmic
microwave background
and we have the teenage years which are
how far back we can look and with james
webb space telescope square kilometer
array and things like that we're gonna
be able to get the baby photos so we're
going to be able to piece together
the life story of the universe pretty
much from beginning to end
and that's going to happen over the next
30 years as well so those are two things
i'm really sure of
we have the whole notion of
gravitational wave astronomy which is
four years old
um there may be a whole level of
richness in there
uh you were showing the uh the
uh
the amazing images with polarization
coming out of the m87 things at the
beginning
and you know that
there's just a whole new world there and
as you say you start being able to do
dynamic movies of that being able to see
how a black hole works those are things
50 years from now who knows the next
level we're going to be up maybe we're
instead of having that whole earth
telescope we're going to have an array
on the moon and here and you're going to
be able to really get uh look at the
horizon incredibly accurately so
i
i but what i think we'll be talking
about
is something you and i can't contemplate
now which is the most exciting thing
yeah i mean we'll probably between you
and me we're still going to be talking
about dark energy and have no idea what
it is that's what i think well along
those lines i got a question there you
know every so often there's a paper
sometimes by
serious people
questioning
your result right questioning whether
the you know accelerated expansion is
real whether the dark energy evidence is
real do you take those papers at all
seriously do you look at them do you
concern yourself with them or how what's
your response to those papers
so i take them seriously
uh
as they deserve to be taken if i can be
honest um when i see someone just taking
weird i've decided to run my new
bayesian tree blah blah blah on your
data and i find that it's only four
sigma rather than seven sigma i'm not
interested i'm sorry that's that's fine
go talk that's a status statistician
thing i'm going to do something i
understand better
dark energy and acceleration is way
bigger than supernovae right it has
things we call baryon acoustic
oscillations so the bumps and wiggles
from the cosmic microwave background
they on their own tell us
because of how big they are now that
acceleration is occurring then you get
to use those same bumps and wiggles in
the galaxies over time and they give the
same answer now yes there's a little
disconnect between
at the seven or eight percent between
the distant and the nearby version of
the hubble constant
but you just can't it's not going to
make it go away so it's like people who
want dark matter to go away
and the first thing they do is we will
not cover the cosmic microwave
background
the baryon acoustic oscillations the
cosmic microwave background are why i
believe dark matter
uh not the rotations of galaxies which i
think add lots of evidence sure but you
can't avoid the whole of evidence when
you just cherry-pick little bits and try
to pop holes in it that's not the way
science works yep so there's a famous
parameter that people use to
characterize the dark energy the
so-called w parameter equation of state
parameter for those in the know those of
you who are listening who know about
this w equals minus 1 is the equation of
state parameter for a true cosmological
consonant do you think that we will
nail down
a value of w that perhaps is different
from -1 through subsequent observations
are you confident that it's all going to
just be the vanilla version of the
cosmological constant going forward
i'm certainly not confident but if i had
to bet
i would be prepared to take
uh ten to one odds that it's going to be
just
vanilla uh
but you don't know until you do
the experiment the question is how many
are you prepared to spend on the
experiment
especially when you know a lot of if you
would say what is the natural value for
w in a dark energy
you know sort of an inflation type you
know and some sort of um
uh
you know particle based version of
what's going on you would expect you
know four or five nines or maybe six
it's not
point minus point nine five
is not a natural number for most exp
most theories and so
it's kind of hard to go out and spend
billions upon billions of dollars
when
you literally don't have a theory that
says
the you know the blah blah blah predicts
this number at the right bit and we
think that's really a beautiful
aesthetically strong theory
so
um
[Music]
i i don't know i mean it's i
my guess is it probably is very close to
minus one
it may be exactly minus one but do i
think it's going to be different enough
from -1 for us to see it my guess is
unlikely i think we're going to run out
of money
uh quite frankly before we can do it
so how do you
how do you view
the mathematical description say of
cosmology as it currently stands do you
view it as
a clever encapsulation of the data
or do you view it as truth
oh
definitely don't see it as truth
um
i see it as
well and the reason let me explain why i
don't say it as truth um
and this is a place where i've moved a
lot in the last 10 years
uh it is very clear that to me that
gravity has to be connected to the other
three forces in a quantum regime
and
i think it is quite likely then that
gravity as we know it is some sort of
emergent phenomena phenomenon
gr is an emergent phenomenon rather than
the truth now it's a very accurate truth
and it's certainly good enough for me
but
my concern is that it is hiding
um a bigger theory
uh that probably
is you know back to when the universe
was 10 to the minus 35 10 to the minus
35th of a second old or something
so
it is i see it as being
a really good approximation but my sense
is
that almost certainly it is not the
defining truth and that's why when
people talk about the singularity of the
big bang i'm completely unconvinced
there's a singularity because i just
don't think general relativity goes back
to the singularity i think it breaks
down at some point yeah do i do that
don't know but you know i that would
make sense to me you know i i that's my
perspective too as i think you know but
but what that leads me to also wonder
about is the following
when we use naturalness arguments in
judging say
w the equation of state for dark energy
and say look minus 1 very natural but
you know minus 0.95 minus 1.05 kind of
unnatural it always makes me wonder yeah
it's unnatural in that particular
mathematical description
but perhaps
as you say that's not the truth maybe
there is another mathematical
description in which
the unnatural number say 0.95 is totally
natural
in that other description that we just
haven't found yet so i'm always
skeptical of i mean i use these
arguments too natural naturalness
arguments but i always in the back of my
mind wonder if we're just fooling
ourselves
well we
and the answer is when you don't know
what's going on it's easy to fool
yourself but let's take for example
curvature of the universe so we know the
universe is very close to
being flat and we know
that uh that is
by
you know i was always told that's kind
of the natural place for it to be very
very close to flat
well guess what the universe was despite
me going come on you guys don't know
what you're talking about and it turns
out it was very very close to flat
and and it is the natural place and it's
why we think things like inflation have
occurred because it's the natural place
for it to land land
so i think there is clearly going to be
a whole range of theories where you
might expect w to be minus one but
you're right the real theory might be
something else
and that's why it would be really really
nice to understand
have a theory that naturally says dark
energy
should be there
at
roughly
the level that it is because we you know
we naturalness the reality is the number
we have measured is not a natural number
it is a terrible weird number that
is one of the reasons it's so hard is
why on earth would it be
not zero and a number so small
where but big enough for us to measure
it's kind of crazy yeah
all right let's let's assume that it is
that and let's assume that it doesn't
change and then let's just for a moment
think about the far future
does it
thrill you
distress you to imagine
that
in some
100 billion trillion years from now the
accelerated expansion if it persists
will give a version of the universe that
could itself deeply mislead observers in
that distant epoch
into thinking that there's nothing else
out there
yeah and i've come full circle on this
one over time as well i think i hang out
with you and people like you too much
because i used to be
you would have you know 20 years ago
when we did it it bothered me i'm like
how can we be in a universe that has a
beginning has no end and we live in this
special time where we can measure
uh and and i i find that very perplexing
i mean you'd never want to be
at a special time
but it does seem like the world we're in
now that is why aesthetically but not
for any other reason right now for me
the idea of us being just one of a
multitude of universes that are
disconnected and go on then
aesthetically i can start dealing with
it this is okay but it's just there's an
infinite number of these going on so
that's just the way it works that i can
deal with then i'm not quite sure i can
express why but it seems
it seems like we're
it's it's then it's quite a natural
thing to be in we're in a universe at a
time
when we can live and exist even though
it's infinite and but there's an
infinite number of them it's it makes it
less less special sure so
that's sort of where i've come to on
this but if if ours is the only universe
then i find it pretty deeply disturbing
yeah yeah no i uh it's uh
you can sort of look at it two ways
you know perhaps
this special time
is also
characteristic of
self-reflective beings right i mean the
conditions necessary for us to even be
here to be able to talk and think about
these things
require certain special conditions too
and they're not independent not
thoroughly independent of each other as
we know if the cosmological constant had
a very different value
you wouldn't have the formation of
structures that are necessary for a
living system such as ourselves
so maybe we should take the specialness
and celebrate it
and and thank our lucky stars literally
that were here
and just interpret it in that most
flat-footed of ways but yes we
scientists of course are generally
happier
if we don't have to tune the dials if it
just
turns out that the most generic
conditions allow the universe as we know
it to persist but that certainly does
not seem to be the universe at the
moment that we're in
um and uh
yeah but if there's a bazillion
universes out there uh of course we will
be in the one that's you know
allows us to me so i can start
talking like i'm talking like a true
string theorist you know right no i i i
it's the only way i can reconcile
the crazy we speak with it
doesn't mean it's right but it's at
least it's i can deal with it
aesthetically yeah no it's uh
uh
to make it just an environmental
condition that has to happen somewhere
in a universe in a multiverse that has
enough universes certainly at least
gives some semblance of an explanation
so i think many people have taken solace
in that but as you say it's a
it's a pretty dramatic move
it's the anti-occam's razor approach if
you will so yeah well i would say it's
almost like finding religion again
in a sense yeah and so where did i
wasn't going to bring it up but you did
so where do you where do you stand on
the uh
i i assume that you're not religious is
that is that i am i am what i describe
as a militant agnostic
i fiercely defend the fact that i don't
know
and at some level i fiercely uh defend
the fact that i don't care
so i have no problem with people being
religious but i'm not and yep that's
fine go do what you need to do so so
einstein in some ways had a similar view
but people love quoting the fact that he
would often invoke the old one god
things of that nature
many of us interpret that as einstein
simply talking about the laws of physics
in a euphemistic poetic language
um but you know would you consider
yourself to be
a spiritual person or is that also too
far afield for that word to be
applicable
no i'm not spiritual at all um i'm quite
the opposite i'm kind of dry and boring
i'm really i live through life as a
bayesian
and
uh i don't you know i talk about
concepts like
god and fate and stuff but i don't
believe them at all i just like you know
life sucks sometimes you just gotta move
on
so so so but when for instance you first
stared at the data and see that the
expansion is accelerating did you get a
little tingle in the spine a little
catch in the throat or was it again just
hey okay bayesian that's where the
bayesian analysis is taking us
no i i my my reaction was oh
christ there goes there goes my club
oh
we're going to be a laughingstock this
is awful this is a career ending
discovery that's what i thought it was
going to be all right final attempt
as you look back on the discovery with
you know hindsight 20 years of hindsight
does it give you an emotional reaction
or is it still very cut and dried the
data that's where it led and so forth
oh no i mean i it was emotional i mean
but i said i was more worried of it just
being crazy and wrong and right
but but no that the journey and the
excitement of realizing it was right ah
that's still very gets my heart going it
was just an amazing thing
to be part of you know we always
you know one of the problems of a nobel
prize i guess is this like oh but you
guys are these amazing geniuses who
uh made this discovery and the answer is
no we were normal people
doing good work like most scientists are
and we ended up being
at the right place at the right time
doing good work and it's sort of like
you we got the ticket to be on the on
the roller coaster at the right time
and it is it's a privilege you know it's
you know it's uh a real privilege to
have been
in such an interesting time
in cosmological history
yeah i mean that's such a
profoundly important message and lesson
especially to the younger folks who may
be listening to us now
that in the end you follow your passion
you see where it leads and if you're
lucky
you'll have a few moments of great
discovery and if you're really lucky one
of those will
yield something like a nobel prize but
in the end you're doing it because
you're driven to do it it's exciting
it's something that catches you at a
deep level and it's something that you
want to do and uh
the prizes are kind of the icing on the
cake
i think that's yeah and that's why when
you said it's the
the highest achievement nobel prize is
the highest recognition recognized
absolutely was the discovery
in 1998 that that to me is you know that
is my
people you know they said what is your
highest achievement i'm like uh well i
i'll have to admit it was this and uh
nothing else is really going to be close
yeah without a doubt well brian thank
you so much for for joining us this is a
a great fascinating conversation i have
no doubt that our audience uh was
thrilled to go on this journey of your
life
and this great discovery and this great
achievement and this great recognition
all wrapped together into into one
powerful package uh i hope to see you
next year at world science festival of
brisbane assuming that the world allows
that kind of travel to take place
and uh no doubt maybe there'll be an
opportunity for our past to cross before
then but if not thank you for joining us
and i look forward to seeing you then
all right thank you very much brian one
brian to another take what be well
absolutely you too
all right guys that was our conversation
with brian schmidt before we wrap up
here let me just see if there are a
couple of
questions in the chat that i might
uh
address
um there was one actually that came in a
little bit earlier i think i may have
written it down someone david perry
sent me an email having to do with uh
the microwave background
radiation and it's a worry that david
raises in his question to me
that i think others may have so it's
perhaps worth spending just a brief
moment on it sometimes when we talk
about the the heat the light left over
from the big bang
you might ask yourself well when we look
up
isn't it a coincidence that that light
just happens to be blowing by
planet earth at this moment so that we
can measure the microwave background
radiation you might think that you know
once it blows by us the radiation will
be gone right and and
it's a natural thought but it it brings
forward a quality of cosmology as we
understand it that's quite
distinct from the intuition that that
question illustrates because
let's imagine a possibility that the
universe is infinitely big space might
go on forever and if that's the case
this microwave background radiation
permeates all of space it's not as
though it took place at one location
and has been traveling outward from that
one location if that were the case then
yeah you'd better be at the right spot
at the right moment for that radiation
to blow by you but if that radiation
fills all of space
then it is going this way and that way
in this way still all of the time
so whenever you look out into the cosmos
there will be a point from which a
photon from that early epoch is just
reaching you
because those photons were released from
every location throughout this infinite
cosmos and therefore there's always a
source
that will
be the relevant one regardless of when
you look out into the night sky so the
microwave background radiation will be
with us in some sense forever it is the
case that in the far future
the temperature
and the redshift of that radiation the
temperature will get so low the redshift
will become so large that in the future
it will be very difficult
to detect the microwave background
radiation but it will still always be
there
nevertheless
um
another question about the microwave
background radiation i see here from
maximilian edgar have we measured the
cmb from other vantage points
like the moon well the measurements of
the microwave background have largely
been taken either from
balloon-based experiments where people
will go up above the atmosphere with
specialized equipment
or from
a telescope that we've launched like the
hubble space telescope or the james webb
when it ultimately goes up these
machines these instruments have the
capacity to measure the microwave
background radiation i do not believe
that anyone's ever
i i think the answer is no
that we've never taken it from them and
i've never heard of it so i do not think
so but ultimately it will be the case
that
we'll
you know
once humanity spreads to other planets
and other star systems then yeah we'll
be able to in principle measure the
microwave background from another
vantage point now our belief is
that because of the homogeneity overall
homogeneity and isotropy
no special directions and no special
positions in the universe our
expectation
is that the measurements won't matter
really where we take them from but
certainly
the confirmation of that expectation by
virtue of taking the measurements from
other locations will
be a valuable thing that ultimately
will be done um what else do we have
here let me uh
switch over to the live chat
and uh yeah i am i cannot read anything
without my glasses on so
let's see what we got um
alexander johnson what does the
expansion of space look like from the
perspective of string theory
and not much different from what brian
schmidt and i were talking about
just a moment ago
within string theory you can have
cosmological models that address the
accelerated expansion in much the same
way imagine that there's a cosmological
constant
you can have other
models of expansion in string theory
that allow for the universe to expand
and then come back and then perhaps
undergo a bounce-like solution
these kinds of evolutions are compatible
with their understanding of strength
they're not picked out
by string theory strength theory
unfortunately isn't understood at a
level yet where from first principles
you just follow the equations and you
say ah ha
this is what happens in the cosmos
accelerated expansion for ever or for a
while unfortunately you can't
get that from first principles but you
certainly can make
models within strength that are
compatible with those observations um
john gombuda says the universe had no
beginning has no end the universe is
conscious it is god i don't know i guess
i'm not um it's hard for me to
respond much to that john
yeah i mean maybe god is behind it
but
the powerful tools of mathematics
allow us to make calculations and
predictions that a god-like explanation
would be
at least from our understanding not able
to do i've never seen any
theological perspective
that can for instance
predict the anisotropies in the
microwave background radiation has
anyone ever done that by just positing
god
and then deducing from that assumption
the
anisotropy's the microwave background
radiation i don't think so but under
modest assumptions using the general
theory of relativity and quantum
mechanics we can make calculations
of the temperature variations across the
night sky and compare those to our
observations and so
the agreement between our observations
and the mathematical calculations
gives us confidence that yeah we don't
have the full story but the mathematical
story that does involve
a beginning and does evolve things
evolving over time according to
mathematical equations it gives us
confidence
that we're tapping into some kind of
truth because the calculations agree
with what we see
and that unfortunately is not something
that we can do with god that doesn't
mean that god is wrong it just means
that the barometer by which you measure
your beliefs are quite different in the
two fields
in cosmology in science we use a
barometer of
predictive power of your ideas to match
observations
in a theological setting people can use
a different barometer they can use a
barometer of does it help me make sense
of my life and if it does fantastic does
it give me some sense of meaning and
purpose yeah for some god is able to do
that and the laws of quantum mechanics
are not able to do that so it's not
that they're really in competition with
each other john i wouldn't frame it the
way that you did personally i would
frame it that there are distinct stories
that we tell about the universe for
different purposes
for
the story that aims to understand
the microwave background radiation and
the evolution of the cosmos in the far
future of the cosmos yeah that
scientific story is pretty good
for another story that tries to give us
some sense of purpose and meaning
the
theological story for some does a very
good job in that domain
and those stories need not be
at each other's throats those stories
can just be viewed as parallel accounts
that play a different role
in our attempt to understand who we are
how we got here
and what the universe within which we
find ourselves what that universe is
all right maybe one or two
oh anas
why did you stop your daily equation i
stopped your daily equation because
it was it was a lot of work i mean it
may not have seemed like a lot of work
but you know every single day to sit
down and try to think up okay what's
today's equation how am i going to
explain it you got to film it you gotta
put a little visual in it you gotta
write out the equations and so forth it
just became
you know it's like many people they have
a diary right and they keep their diary
for i don't know a couple weeks couple
months some people do it forever but
very few
why because every day writing in that
diary becomes
a burden right it becomes a chore
becomes something that you do instead of
the other things that you might want to
do in your life and that's certainly
what happened with your daily
equations so that was what led us to
shift over to these kinds
of conversations and i should note that
we're getting to a place soon where the
world science festival new york i
mentioned world science festival
brisbane that's happening right now and
again for you guys in australia
you know you should
you know get up to brisbane if you're
not there partake of the weekend's
activities that are going to be a lot of
youth and family events really a good
time up there in brisbane so you should
feel free
to do that but world science festival
new york will be kicking into
gear in a digital online way toward the
end of may early june so there'll be all
sorts of programs that
will be far
more produced than your daily equation
talking about
all sorts of subjects i'm going to be
doing a program
on the relationship between math and
reality we had a little bit of that
conversation with brian schmidt but i'm
going to be in conversation with a
handful of other people
philosopher david albert mathematician
physicist philosopher shelly goldstein
a couple other max tegmark
will be in that program sylvia jonas
will be in that program as well
may also do a program on um a book a
recent book that i wrote until the end
of time we're thinking of making a sort
of stage digital stage version of that
making that available during world-sized
vessel new york anyway these are all
plans in the making but there's a lot of
stuff so you should keep your eyes out
and you will not miss your daily
equation one single bit when all of that
program starts programming starts to
be released as we go forward
okay anything else that i should talk
about before
we wrap this up um
let's see um
ken and carol says he is too smart i
guess you're talking about brian schmidt
sadly not me but okay no problem um
um what do we have here um oh
important man asks what if the redshift
is due to aging photons and not
acceleration this is an idea that that
people floated or continued to float
from time to time we used the redshift
as brian schmidt was talking about to
understand the motion
of of distant galaxies and the idea is
if distant galaxies are rushing away
from us
the light that they emit
gets stretched out
by the cosmic expansion and root as that
photon is traveling enroute to us
and that we believe is the explanation
of
why it is that the light is shifted
toward the red others said well maybe
that's not what's going on maybe you
know the photons just get tired they
just kind of lose energy in some sense
even that's compatible with the
explanation i just gave but some that
tried to argue that you don't need the
expansion of the universe you don't need
distant objects to be rushing away from
us
and the point that brian schmidt made
is really worth bringing up in answer to
this question which is we don't base
our
conclusions about the expansion of the
universe the accelerated expansion of
the universe the flatness of the
geometry of space we don't base that on
one observation
we base it on a concordance
of a whole variety of observations that
have to do with looking at the distant
objects looking at the size
of the temperature variations in the
microwave background radiation looking
at the theoretical structures that can
explain these qualities of the world
looking at the baryon acoustic
oscillations that give rise to a very
precise statistical variation of the
temperature in the microwave
part of the spectrum and it's by
collecting all of this data and finding
a model that's able to explain the
intricacies of all of these observations
that we
are led to the picture that we espouse
this idea of an expanding universe and
accelerating expanding universe so it's
not it's not one observation which
perhaps you may
find some way of shaking confidence and
that it's many observations many
distinct and complementary observations
that all come together to yield our most
refined cosmological story and so that's
why
we have confidence in it it all holds
together
all right i think i'm gonna
wrap it up now guys um so keep your eyes
out for
another one of these sessions probably
in a couple weeks we took a little time
off because of world science festival
brisbane happening right now
around the end of may early june we'll
probably also take a break because we'll
be focusing on getting the programming
out for world science festival new york
mark your calendars world science
festival in new york i think will start
wednesday june 2nd i could be wrong but
roughly the first wednesday after
memorial day in the united states will
be the launch of the digital version of
world science festival new york
sign up to the world science festival
newsletter you can subscribe to this
channel i don't know it's somewhere
around
the screen that you see in front of you
i don't know where it is at the moment
it's either over here over here whatever
find it
and we have a wonderful
schedule of programming that we are
going to be releasing look for that and
look for the next of these live sessions
so my thanks to the world science
festival team my thanks to brian schmidt
for joining us for a fascinating
conversation on cosmology for the most
part a little bit on science policy in
order that we could hit
his new day job brian schmidt's new day
job in the academic hierarchy the
academic world of
australian universities and going
forward we will have conversations again
that run the gamut from science to
science policy cosmology neuroscience
you let us know what you want us to
focus upon and i'm happy to
work with the world science festival
team to find the leading voices on
whatever subject matter
you find particularly interesting that
you'd like us to cover all right so
until we meet again probably in a couple
of weeks this is brian green from
world science festival in new york city
signing off
[Music]
do
[Music]
you